I just want to look good for you good
for you uh-huh
I love that song myself and Biddy and
Natalie and Shaun and Danielle we were
we're here in Disney World and we were
singing that song all day yesterday we
were walking around Epcot Center and
Epcot Center is amazing by the way if
any you guys ever get a chance you
should really check out Disney World
this is much for adults as it is for
kids it's really like a little bit of
everything for everyone and and I
definitely enjoy I have enjoyed my time
here but anyway so so I'm making this
video to let you guys know that I have a
book coming out it's called behind the
cave breaking down the ultimate comic
book hero and it's it's about it's about
Superman it's the history of Superman I
mean I'd go into detail on everything
that I could find that I could make
sense of that I you know understand
about the character you know from the
time of when he was first created before
he was created what led up to his
creation after he appeared in comics the
whole Batman Superman rivalry that went
on the legal issues that were
encountered over the years I went
through all that stuff and and I'm
really proud of of what I've done and I
also wanted to just say thanks to you
guys because you know without this
without without your all support this
never would have been possible and and
it kind of amazes me that you know
because you guys watch the videos that I
make it's it's made it possible you know
for from angle polishing to reach out to
me and say hey you know we love to have
you write a book for us and and the
results is what's currently available
now now of course there are multiple
ways to get it if you're you know if
you're anything like me and when I want
something I want it now I don't want it
now like I want it right now you know I
don't I don't like having a way your
best bet is to go to Barnes & Noble to
your local bars the noble store and and
pick it up there
here's that where I go for all the books
that I get and and plus the Spartan
novel like when they told me that my
book was gonna be in Barnes & Noble I
was just like oh my god
because I went to Barcelona as a kid for
those of you guys who don't know the
whole backstory of when I was when I was
younger than anything I went to bars my
dad took me to parts of note wards where
I got my first book and I guess the
first book book like my first book was
in libraries and stuff got a Vitara what
happens going off on tangents let's reel
this back in when I was a kid my dad
took me to Barnes & Noble let me buy a
book and it was it was like the art of
war or something like that it seemed
like it made sense at the time
and it's the popular book that everyone
knows about so like buying this book
makes me smart right and from there I
just I've always gone back there and
bought books and stuff that's this it's
one of the stores that's available and
it's my preferred one so um so I
definitely go there and and and check it
out you know I'm amazed it's gonna be a
problem though it's like one of the best
bookstores in the world but uh but yeah
so so anyway um so thank you to you guys
out there so it's all my fans those of
you who have helped me to to get to this
point you know without you guys this
wouldn't have been possible I mean if
this would not have been possible
without you guys so so you all are
awesome for that but I'm gonna go ahead
and get going I think we're gonna meet
up here in the next little bit and we're
gonna grab some lunch and then we're
gonna go to to the Animal Kingdom which
I'm really excited about because I've
never been to the Animal Kingdom before
and India so I will catch you all later
please